this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
good afternoon to you breaking news big
changes again once again for the las
vegas raiders thank you for joining us
here at noon i'm heather mills raiders
owner mark davis tweeting this morning
raiders president dan ventrelli is out
of the organization he'd been with the
raiders for 18 years served as president
since july 2021. eight news now sports
reporter ron futrell here to talk more
about what this means yeah here we go
heather we're only months away from the
start of the nfl season but things are
brewing in the raiders front office this
week raiders president dan ventrelli no
longer with the team we'll get to the
statement in a moment now ventrelli was
named interim gm after mark bedan
he resigned in july of last year that
one came as a shocker but dane had been
with the raiders for 30 years he was
basically a family friend also ventrelli
had been with the raiders for 18 years
working in the front office negotiating
players contracts leases
oh also
yesterday jeremy aguero resigned from
the raiders he was their chief operating
officer now here's the only thing the
raiders have said today in a statement
quote from owner mark davis dan
ventrelli is no longer with the raiders
organization we will have no further
comment at this time
end quote sort of short okay this is
pretty unusual to have this much change
over in a front office in this short a
time period mark bedan and two others
gone less than a year ago remember when
that happened now ventrelli and aguero
both gone in two days the raiders
actually begin their voluntary workouts
later this month
in henderson so the players gonna have
to get busy i'm ron futrell live local
now